brad jeff congratulations you made it to
the final round of this competition now
we're gonna send you home for five days
to recreate an iconic weapon from
history that weapon is
the
skiavona
rising to popularity in italy during the
16th and 17th centuries the ski avona
became the trusted weapon for
mercenaries recruited to guard the
venetian head of state the sword's long
blade included multiple fullers to
lighten its weight while its straight
double edge made it conducive for deadly
thrusts and cuts the most eye-catching
feature of this blade was its basket
hilt with multiple pieces of steel that
intertwined to protect the hand from
brutal slashes its attractive yet deadly
qualities are why the ski of ona can
still be found today in popular games
such as assassin's creed good luck blade
smiths we'll see you in five days
my name is jeff wagoner i love blade
smithing but i'm a power lineman by
trade i work up on the high lines
restore power when there's storms i
don't know how i got into that because
i'm basically afraid of three different
things heights electricity and women
this sword is going to be hard enough to
build but the handles
i'd say damn near impossible but i'm
here for a reason and the reason is to
win it i'm not ready to get to the
grinder but it has to be done my biggest
fear right now is if i don't get my heat
treat right and i start getting a big
warp in it i'll be running around like a
chicken with my head cut off
big work
i have to find a way to straighten my
blade somehow so i put it up on my two
by fours and i tried to do a counter
band
if this does not work i am screwed
looks like i got the bend out now i can
specialize on that handle and the guard
and just make it immaculate i'm learning
as i go
seems like a lot of the competitions
lately been really close so it's just
down to fit and finish
it feels pretty damn good
i just want to see if it'll cut through
a rope
i worked on that little one
my guard ended up rubbing on my knuckles
quite a bit
i don't have enough time to fix it so
hopefully it doesn't rub the judges like
it rubbed me but we're gonna see i am
excited to see it compete
my name is brad mcdougall i'm 46 and i
live in north granby connecticut i love
being on a farm and i'm just so excited
to start hammering that's really all i'm
thinking about is hammering i just want
a hammer
the first thing i want to do is get the
blade hammered out
the blade is down to less than a quarter
inch thick so that's good
baby
the blade is about 40 inches long so i'm
just hoping that it's not gonna bend
i wonder how often they're bent
it's straighter than when i put it in
i'm so excited now i can focus on making
the hill so my biggest issue i'm worried
about is time
i hope it goes well
my hand's shaking
i'm gonna get the handle finished
i'm gonna use the old italian riding
boots and wrap the handle with some
leather then get everything fitted
together properly
this is
crazy looking all right blitz bits as
you can see i'm still recovering from an
injury
so to be my arm today and have the
pleasure of testing your weapon i'd like
to bring back one of my favorite
students
my brother r.j marquetta
[Music]
all right brad the one issue i have
about your handle right here it did
cause some issues by rubbing against the
thumb right there
but more importantly it is a sharp blade
for slashing and thrusting it will kill
cool
jeff you ready
let's do this
[Music]
one right here
okay
all right jeff a little bit on the
inside of your basket hilt right there
it did dig in into his knuckles
but overall if we're talking about a
killing blade here with good balance and
the kind of destruction it did
it will kill
good job
all right bladesmiths next stop is a
strength test
ben
to test your shivona's basket and blade
i'm gonna punch into these terracotta
pots and then chop into these birch logs
and remember it's not what happens to
the valves or the wood it's what happens
to your blade
brad you're up first you ready my shia
vona is definitely ready
well brad once i started chopping into
that log it was just going the whole
time
there is a tiny little deformation right
there
it's pretty narrow
you can hear it you know
all in all it's sharp and it's a good
chopper nice to be done thank you
all right jeff you're up you ready let's
do this
[Music]
nice
well jeff
this is a heck of a chopper it's got a
lot of forward weight it's a little bit
on the heavy side but not too much
in general and in total it held up very
well nice job thank you
all right gentlemen this is our
sharpness test a rope and sandbag slash
what i'll do to test the edges of your
blade is slice the rope releasing the
sandbag then cut the bag what we want to
see are good clean cuts through the rope
and clean cuts through the bag brad
you're up first you ready ready
okay brett on the cuts
pass through the rope with no problem
this blade has a beautiful edge
a fine cutter excellent well done thank
you
jeff you ready let's get it on all right
let's do this
i think right now we're almost dead even
couldn't be any closer
all right jeff what i like about your
blade is it's look this industrial look
it's cool
it didn't slice all the way through the
bag but it cuts very cleanly
nicely done
thank you
brad jeff you are both extraordinary
weaponsmiths
but there can only be one for it to fire
champion
jeff congratulations
you are our newest forged and fire
champion brad unfortunately your weapon
did not make the cut fred this is
probably the most difficult hilt design
we have sent any of our smith's home to
do and you both did a really nice job
and we had to look at the finest of
details and that that rolled edge you
took in the strength test
and that's why we've got to send you
home
brad please surrender your weapon
i did the best that i could and i put
every single bit of effort into my blade
and jeff i hope we become friends
forever
i definitely have a lot to learn from
you
and i'm just so close to being the
champion
jeff you are the new forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
my heart's pounding out of my chest this
is what i came here to do please present
your weapon to the judges
i feel freaking awesome this is
everything this is what i want
it's perfect
i heard brendan might have called me
magic mike but tell you what the magic
is floating baby magic is floating
you